got a news flash on the tour for all you
bozos and homies
though we're adding second shows over
there in Toronto and Denver tickets are
flying off the shelves and we added a
third show in Chicago scoop them up
don't get left out in the cold baby yeah
gang tickies are going quick we're also
going to be in Phoenix Salt Lake La San
Diego Washington D.C Pittsburgh Buffalo
Pontiac Michigan uh Minneapolis
Minnesota Madison Wisconsin Milwaukee
Wisconsin Sacramento California San
Francisco San Jose and Philadelphia well
that's for sure going to sell out soon
get those tickets we'll see you there we
love you gang scoop them up gang welcome
to another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage hey it's that little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find that the group to
be classy yeah or they're just a big old
piece of trash I'm your host Dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're out back here at hoodies in the
new edition baby oh yeah got the [__]
Tony Hawk up on the wall uh-huh living
high on the hog out here and Cody just
got busted over at the Acme stealing rib
eyes Okay so good news is we're having
steak tonight bad news is you got to
cook them all right okay my co-host is
coming he's been really [__] icing me
on easily oh no no no no my co-host put
that don't put that on me prick that he
is coming at you from across the table
he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is Mr
Neptune 2005. ready to head back down
the shore with the boys and show them
how to shake it up on the waves oh yeah
give it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan
everybody what up baby thanks for tuning
in as always please make sure you rate
if you subscribe on iTunes oh yeah the
full video available over there on
YouTube as you know those numbers are
obviously one of the greatest two
websites of all time
www.patreon.com
you get like a bajillion hours of
content we just passed 10 000
subscribers thank you enough love you
again shout out to the [__] homies
yeah and then also
www.ru garbage.com you sign up over you
go over there you get tickets to all the
[__] live shows on the state trashy
tour baby but you're moving those picks
are moving third show added in Chicago
that's gonna go second show out in
Toronto that's gonna go second show at
it in Denver that's gonna go low tickets
in L.A might even be going by the time
this comes out who knows Philly's move
and everywhere is going Chicago [__]
DC get those dicks plenty of tickets in
DC
bring the family you know I mean call
the boys call the girls call whoever you
got come out and see us Jesus Christ and
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good give it up for
Toby T-Bone McMullen everybody what up
dudes hey pal dude I cannot wait to get
over the Border in Toronto to get my
hands on some of that poutine brother
really I can't wait gravy and Fries what
are we doing come on I was an old I was
was an elder man when I first learned
about that that seems crazy but all in
my wheelhouse I want to go to the strip
club that's what I was thinking do that
here yeah you can also put gravy on
fries here apparently I want to see if
their boobs are different
Canadian boobs they're little Leafs
oh I heard they were I heard the strip
clubs are good up there I think that's
Montreal is known for their strip clubs
I believe Toronto might as well I just
know Montreal is all right I can't do
the putina money of zampies
I'm not dab on it now I get sick to my
TomTom but I'm sure they have other
other Delicacies up there sure thing of
Flapjacks for sure I mean I think
Toronto uh Flapjacks yeah pancakes you
know Toronto is like the size of New
York it's not it's not like there's not
like log cabins and [__] it's like oh
[__]
I need to buy it's probably like a five
million popular there's like skyscrapers
and stuff so I'm sure they have pancakes
okay all right I just think you think
Canada's like that's just gonna be
people playing hockey on a pond it's a
city I know it's a city have you been to
Canada no I haven't but I've been I'm a
world traveler now I've been out of the
country once yeah yeah okay sure
sure
what do you think what do I think have
you been to Toronto I don't know I've
just never heard any but I think you're
equating all of Canada to Toronto I
think titties and maple syrups is a
pretty good reason to go call me an
[__] I don't know I never called you
an [__] I just never heard anybody go
oh Toronto I hear they got good pancakes
up there trying to get my hands on some
of these sticky titties
after I get through with them all right
quit screwing around I wanted to ask you
is this
um got any Pancakes on you no I wanted
to ask you this I'm listening I'm here
uh
the birds away
okay sure I'm home with the kitty cat
um I wanted to ask you a little cleaning
up you know you're trying to keep the
place nice is it trashy
to run the vacuum cleaner on the couch
because if it is I'm guilty of it and it
works so well
it's fantastic you gotta run the cleaner
on that thing
uh spot I'm sure it's effective
it's dirty though is it yeah because I
have rolls all over those that's getting
all the dirt on the floor and then
you're putting that onto the carpet
essentially the bottom of the couch the
car the couch I apologize the bottom of
a vacuum is seen better days you gotta
give me that are you using the extendo
no I'm talking yeah dude he's that's
like he's like treating like a John
Deere he's up there that's like using
the backyard hose on your truck dude on
the car interior I'm like patented the
Battle of the Bulge it down it's like
Fury you kidding me uh yeah I don't
that's not uh I get it for surface area
uh you know it really knocks it out man
it really knocks it out
yeah it's a good time I wouldn't do it
yeah I don't think so I don't think you
should how do you cleaning your couch we
have a couch cleaner come
on no you know I swear to God we do you
have a couch cleaner come yeah like
somebody that comes in like it cleans
the upholstery she my lady what yeah
separate from the cleaning lady that you
got yeah who blows you up online ah she
does and also it doesn't do a great job
you have a separate couch cleaner person
that shows up at the house yeah who are
you
they're not coming weekly well he bought
a white couch against my better judgment
my wife bought like a cream couch and
then my fat ass is weird too what a
cream-colored couch I told her not to do
it now we got a goddamn dog got a
hellhound my fat ass is sweating on that
thing how much yay you mule
cream colored couch yeah [__] Frank
Lucas it looks good with the tiger
statues but
that's yeah someone's got to do it the
marble countertops
you know what I was thinking too you
know it's uh it's cool but it's pretty
trashy is it true everything is it
everything that's pretty cool is trashy
and I'm on board there's a track to have
a gun like like a like a musket on the
wall did you know anybody I thought you
just meant in general
uh let's have a Beretta on the wall now
growing up uh yeah growing up my aunt uh
I don't know now that I think about it
but I would look up at that thing that
thing might as well have been 80 feet
long I would have taken out a couple two
tree records
that that thing had some of King
Charles's blood on it
whoa yeah it was a rifle was it was it a
musket they didn't have bayonets on it
back in the day oh no this was like a
rifle with the bay I don't know when
it's from now it might have been from
WW2 and M4 yo the neighbor's been
talking [__] fixed bayonets yeah well it
was in Port Richmond too yo get your
bayonet and meet me on Gold Street man
if I if they ever made that because I
was in a war and they made that call
fixed bayonets I'd be [__] in my pants I
mean you [__] in your pants last week on
the way home from work here we go who
broke them what's going on dude that's
that's that's Petra I always thought it
was Civil War but that doesn't make any
sense now that no they did have much
Civil War because you only get one shot
and you throw the knife on it
start slicing yeah but that thing would
have had to be like a bayonet from the
Civil War just in a in a row home in you
know that's where we were well that's
where my hands so that's where we grow
that's what I think we're talking about
in the war they weren't fighting house
to house in South Philly
uh uh but I don't think they would have
a civil war memorabilia in the kitchen
it was in the dining room of course cut
the turkey nothing says like a nice
family dinner to set the appetite and
some [__] bloody bayonets yeah I'll
be seeing like a log cabin or like a
hunting cabin or something like that you
know if if your family did that I could
see that uh-huh yeah no this was just in
my my aunt's house that's up there with
the samurai swords on the wall man I
remember my buddy had those that guy was
single and ready to mingle the three of
them the short one the strikeout King
man but then you'd always try to grab
them and they'd be like loose and you
know what I mean that handle was always
[__] up be careful it's not bad bad
already
something yeah that's that uh rifle with
a Bayonet do you have anybody in World
War II maybe they brought it over I'm
sure somebody was but not that I know of
I mean sure
I don't think Irish mutts down there
[__] throwing bricks and Woody over
there somebody's numbering I called up
for sure they're all walking forward
like this
hahaha
what'd you say about me Mom
he moved me bins so Jerry's looking for
a fight is he
all right you want to fight
so the king's looking for a fight eh a
couple of Sullivan boys over there
there was there was uh five Sullivan
Brothers that were that were uh famous
in World War II they all they all died
in the same Battleship which is what
Saving Private Ryan is about isn't it
yes and that's both of my names yeah
Ryan's and the Sullivan they changed it
to the yeah fighting Sullivans the it
was great movie man great movie in the
the 50s I know a crew of those out of
Kensington still
shout out to cousin Mike and the boys
I'm not talking about it christening
thinking about taking air fire from a
zero yeah the fighting Sullivans the guy
who played uh
um Uncle Jimmy in uh
in a wonderful life was the father in
The Fighting Sullivans great movie in
real life no no in the in the movie they
made a movie about it okay yeah and
that's they changed that rule that like
brothers can't the same thing they all
can't be deployed at the same they're
like they're on the same ship or
something yeah there's some sort of rule
from it yeah yeah
um
but yeah no no Samurai stuff growing up
my buddy I remember I think your mom was
a teaching karate
I don't know what she was doing to make
ends meet she was doing something uh I
remember my buddy's brother had it and
he like I remember him walking me into
the room and to show them off sure the
older brother was like hey it was my
first time over at the house it was like
check these out this is a little risque
where's your mom keep the Brandy let's
[__] keep to get this [__] [__] out
so I can get after it dude you got an
open crib right here what's a what's a
famous Brandy I can see the bottle oh
man the headache that would give you
well that's all you had well when you
put iced tea and everything else uh-huh
the apricot brandy uh the Seagram's is
it no it's like J M or yeah
baby yeah yeah we've talked about e j
what's uh hold on let me see that it's
uh well what I was gonna ask you and I'm
not implying by any stretch of the
imagination this is a little risque okay
was your mom a robe person
did you
did you did your mom walk around in a
room and stuff
did you ever see her canes because I had
a couple of boys where they wore like
the I'm a sailor on leave robe you know
like this like the satin the satin short
ones oh covering the nips with a [__]
still swinging
like a kimono
like Will Ferrell
Wedding Crashers at the end ah
see the little guy peeking out hello
that's swinger [__] right there Patty
wore a robe in the winter but it was
like a thick you know it was like a
parka sure and she would she would a man
she used to gag us in the morning
because [__] she'd throw out the
apples and cinnamon oatmeal the Quaker
apples and cinnamon oatmeal but if it
was the winner and she wasn't feeling
well she'd have the sniffles dude the
the tissue went right in her sleeve oh
yeah
Denise was known for that I would use
the like the world's grossest magician
and when I watch me
dude
yeah are these your germs
raging a heartburn an hour after you
left the house because of the oatmeal
and you start getting the sniffies later
on in the day that Denise was big for
that uh I would used to go run you know
back as a young team that's Chris she's
a young lady I'm surprised you know it's
an older lady thing no it would be uh I
mean she wasn't you know she wasn't
burying them like they were like she's a
squirrel and they're acorns but from
time to time I would be I would have to
run the pockets to find a couple extra
bucks oh in the jacket Jam you up oh man
I'm reaching in there it's just gonna
find a mouse trap in there
it's just [__] tissue oh my God this
has been in here for three seasons oh
crumpled up I remember one time I made a
score of all scores dude I must have
made about 80 bucks I was living high
and then that finally came around yeah
because you know she couldn't be out 80
but I found like 11 here 9 there 20 here
that was a good part of the day in the
summer as a kid what is ripping the hat
like toss in the house uh-huh that would
that's going into the closet in the hall
and be like let's get to the back of
this thing yeah dude let's open up the
shoe shine kit see if they're hiding an
old revolver in here or something
foreign
[Laughter]
and I got lucky because so we had that
right and then my stepdad moved in with
a bunch of cool [__] [__] I had never
explored before sure [__] not for kids
guns firecrackers knives just [__]
I'd open up his drawer and just [__]
yeah it was start Root find whatever I
could find but I was also like if I got
caught with my mom that's one thing but
if I got called
it was a convo that I didn't want to
[__] have catch an ass beating for
that listen the fat ones going through
my stuff again listen again we're
basically roommates
you stay in your room dude
sandwich
uh
yeah that was big though going through I
loved going through [__] rooting rooting
what are you still in rooting well I was
just left to my devices for Seoul
especially those Summers if when
I say I was like 12 or 11 10 whatever
like my brother and sister were working
right at that point they're 16 18
whatever they're out
I'm [__] I'm just at the crib by
myself no car no nothing Ma's at work
step dad's at where I'm just like it's
we would cook that's what we would do me
and my brother would cook uh-huh we'd
get hamburgers and make uh like homemade
Salisbury steaks just like just keep
frying them in the pan dousing them with
A1 steak sauce Jesus oh yeah
that's what I came up with uh noodles
all of Foley
which was spaghetti and uh cream of
mushroom soup
delicious little salt and pepper a
little parm cheese
okay put you a nice little coma for the
afternoon air conditioner is cooking put
the feet up couple of ice pops good
knocked kids going night night
uh uh all right yeah uh but let's get
into it again we got a gosh darn Family
episode uh as you know when you join the
patreon we will answer your garbage
question on the air uh it's just the
best way to do it you gotta become a
homie you get a crack at it baby you
know what I mean uh this one's from
cereal is it garbage for your dad to get
a Hooters t-shirt signed by all the
waitresses after lunch on a summer
vacation man P.S I was 10 and my mom
threw it away when she found it of
course that's who does he think they are
what do you mean they get their
autograph
that's what I'm saying wait I'm
interpreting this as the family went on
vacation then they went to Hooters that
much
what
wait
that you said they got it on family
vacation so they went to Hooters yeah
the dad they went to Hooters yeah I
guess I don't know if the mom was there
okay the dad asked all the waitresses
before he left lunch to sign my Hooters
t-shirt like they're famous honey I just
love the team yeah I was a big fan of
the squad like they're not some scavots
in Tampa or something you know what I
mean with a pill problem anything like
that would have been there would have
been retribution yeah to even get into a
Hooters we went to one one time as a as
like a gimmick I think it was all the
dads
is my brother's soccer team and all they
might have must have been like 14 maybe
it was all the dads there was like
nothing really around wherever the
tournament was or the game sure there
wasn't I gotta go to show and tell Boys
Blue right buddy Applebee's parking lot
they're connected
uh and they went I remember like even
then it was like yeah this is [__]
everybody was like this isn't
this is just a throw at a decent Wing
over there though I'll tell you that
yeah now Buffalo uh Buffalo fried shrimp
ain't too shabby my friend used to work
there
nice lady and we would go visit her
buddy of yours Mike hey
we haven't got any tables it was crazy
[Applause]
we'll have this guy on the tip list we
would go and hang out I am assuming we
were relatively efficient to be like
yeah we know [__] Megan or what you
would go and hang out and I came off
wrong Bozo no since we ended a bar we
went once or twice maybe when she was
working we went in for lunch or dinner
get shot down
a couple more of these [__] crab
fritters strike out oh it's a strikeout
chicken sandwich please uh-huh
so please stop looking at me special
yeah I don't know if we ever ever you
know I remember being there and I'm
assuming
I was open to any problems
for extra Ranch
he's talking about real estate deals
right
how old were you what how old were you
are we talking you're a blue collar guy
or are you rolling in business cash oh
this is probably that's when you were
selling the aluminum siding or whatever
I got a lanyard around my neck
hey we're working on a job in your
neighborhood I figured I'd stop by and
strike out with the waitresses
that's what I used to have to say uh a
lot of guys probably bothering you here
huh don't worry we're cool so what time
do you get off
um
I I was probably right out of high
school maybe 18 maybe going into college
maybe oh so you're not boozing well I
think we were going there because we
would get served now that that comes up
I think she'd be like hey come sit down
I'll give you two tree beers sure you
know you can oogle that Rachel or
whatever you know the girl in the next
section and uh yeah I mean I probably
had like Gene Carpenter jean shorts on
and a polo with a stain on it smoking in
there probably probably smoking two tree
beers trying to look adult ripping
heaters yeah I'm going to Temple next
year coughing some girl looking at a
cross-eyed 16 year old can't be going I
don't own a phone actually yeah sorry oh
I'm so sorry
yeah that yeah oh man that's man that's
just brought up it was over there on
Street Road too
okay right next to Michael's aka the
wrinkle ranch we're gonna share some
wings
can you push somebody on the tree
it's only two here let's talk about mint
mobile shout out tournament mobile shout
out to Mr Ryan Reynolds mint mobile baby
trying to help you save a couple of
bucks as you know inflation is running
wild you can't get a dozen eggs or a
thing of milk you get jammed up guess
the avocado toast goodbye bozos and I
assume since inflation is such a big
that mint mobile is raising their prices
no they're not 15 bucks a month starting
over there I know look at that no brick
and mortar they pass the savings right
on the hill all done online get yourself
on mint Mobile today yeah they have
plans starting just 15 beans a month 15
the first company to sell premium
wireless service online only probably
not a 5G Network though well why would
you even bring up something so stupid
like you you're a 5G you got 5G it's
memorable get that you're writing checks
your butt candy I don't know what I'm
talking about switching so easy my butt
can catch plants I better believe it uh
and it saves money with mint mobile what
my butt it also broke through chairs
this week uh switching so easy keep your
same phone your phone number all your
contacts the only thing that changes is
your bill it's fantastic I've said for
years my wife uses it it's easy peasy to
get your new Wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get that plan shipped
right to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage one more time cut
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
at mintmobile.com garbage do it okay
let's talk about Adam and Eve baby talk
about a little sex on the beach let's
talk about calling all freaks calling
all freaks [__] who likes to get
weird baby Scallywags and skeezers
Daniel like sticking stuff up your butt
yeah sure we all do put your wiener in
something of course come on spice things
up a little bit have a little goddamn
fun who knows when this crazy World's
Gonna end it'll be tomorrow it could be
tomorrow finger yourself dude the
double-sided dildo you might need to
fight off the zombies who knows gang
everybody likes having a good time
everybody likes having a good time in
the privacy of their own home and that
is all right get over to Adam and he
even pick up something fun for your for
your loved one or for yourself yeah
right now you can get 50 off just any
one just about any item plus free
shipping and Rush processing in case you
got a hard on it won't go away
huh
[Laughter]
don't wait better sex is just a click
away there you go 50 off one item free
shipping with free Rush processing go to
just go to adamandeve.com select any one
item enter the code garbage to check out
this is an exclusive offer just for our
listeners be sure to use the code
garbage to get your discount 100 free
shipping and Rush processing that's
adamandeve.com promo code garbage
adamandeve.com code garbage donut back
to the shop back to the show uh yeah
it's a tough look stay out of I mean we
went to a Hooters on the road somewhere
yeah lovely lovely yeah yeah they're fun
as a family steer clear there's a family
as a sports bar we've been on the road
and jammed up sometimes where it's like
the only place you can watch a game or
something or a fighter or something that
was happening uh where do we go I think
we're in San Antonio went to a Twin
Peaks remember that that's their ice in
the beer
Frosty yeah remember we ordered those
beers and they came like they were like
the coldest beers we ever had
I we didn't know what it was and then we
all put it together when the ladies with
you know gazunga's walked up to the
table we were like oh Twin Peaks oh I
went to an Ironside Brewery not that
long ago delicious meal what's that have
to do with anything no okay quality
casual dining establishment okay fair
enough The Waitresses have huge jugs or
something
it's an older lady okay
she ran a robe
uh all right this one's from ajk you
didn't answer me about the robe by the
way
uh no maybe in the winter but like she
would have like
she would just be wearing that she would
have like sweatpants on and a shirt and
then like put that on over if she was
cold yeah I mean it wasn't a [__]
whorehouse
this is a [__] she's a refined woman
what about your moms you're all around
in a robe Jesus Christ's my mother
I'm asking I said all due respect
oh yeah chop it up yeah your dad wear a
robe oh yeah
that's classy
no no it is you would what you would
have to do to catch my dad oh yeah my
dad would never he did have a blue one
though that maybe I did see once or
twelve but I mean like I think he slept
in jeans I don't think he's but his
boots tied up my dad was tighty whities
all day my dad would go robe cup of tea
in the morning with the paper
what's under the robe what's up a big
old wee-wee Alfresco a confusingly small
penis actually
uh you [__] rat yeah shut the [__] up
I'm sorry Dad yeah don't they listen
[__] scumbag
sorry we're not all Mondo freaks around
girl next to power plants
okay uh
uh taking shots I'll wipe your ass you
son of a [__] uh all right let's see
this one's from ajk ten dollar bills
though is it garbage if your mom talked
to a ghost to help solve a 15 year old
Cold Case P.S it was installed and the
cops put out on the suspect list
[Music]
[Applause]
turn around
[Laughter]
uh I need a man I wish there was more I
need more of that
is a corporation for mom talk to a ghost
to help solve a 15 year old Cold Case
P.S it wasn't solving the cops put hair
on the suspect list sure
what is she doing what I wonder if it's
a job that she or she this is all
freelance
or is she on the case some like did
somebody give her authority to solve
this case why is she trying to solve the
case
you know what I mean sounds like they
had their eye on her to be honest with
you this is all smoke and mirrors trying
to shake them off the tail I know a lie
when I see one it was Gary with the
Candlestick in the conservatory yikes
maybe she's some kind of medium
you know murderer fair enough
that's uh yeah anything like that yeah
if you're pulling up to a Precinct with
a rusty gun going a ghost told me where
this was because ghost told me where the
bodies were I swear oh look at that he
dropped a knife crazy
hey look over there
she didn't do it
um
any family members do the medium thing
yeah more than uh oh yeah more than I
would you know be willing to admit oh
yeah uh-huh recently yes the whole Squad
yours oh yeah it's big there's something
going on in the water of Philly where
someone passes and they all go well we
talked to Gary's you know
yeah yeah okay let's get the beers
outside
first it was a 23 and me and then it was
that's the anyway we're gonna go see
yeah there's there's I think there's
like two or three of these mediums
floating around the Greater Philadelphia
area line in their pockets
yeah it's more reading the obituaries
it's it seems like every time I talk to
someone from home there's a new somebody
a friend a family a cousin a this or
that they're all talking to somebody
yeah and I don't think it's on the cuff
either sat down with Mr Julia last night
what I don't know whatever her name is
but as like Kath there's also Catholic
isn't that like an affront to the to the
thing to like sacrilegious is what it is
blasphemy
I don't know because I think they're in
their head they're talking to them in
heaven I guess
I know
it's all what are they doing on a split
level in [__] Delaware County
they're up in Paradise
hop on the R5 yeah I don't uh
is there a Rudy a Randy a Richie oh yeah
Richie
I was almost named Richie if I was a boy
yeah a lot of that oh man that's Patty
Foley written all over it talk about
connecting the dots well yeah actually
we live down the street from a Richie he
was 17 houses down I saw him once
walking outside oh he's on the line he's
gonna grab your your uncle or whatever
yeah just tell the fat one to go into
those epics
uh yeah that's uh that's a tough one I
think any time you're anytime you gotta
go to a a ghost a crack a case or
something a little wonky yeah uh
although I wouldn't mind doing it
I don't want anything to do with that I
think that opens up to this bad news huh
you don't know what you're who you're
taking home with you
yikes I don't think it's that you got
the old Henderson murderer
that [__] Grim Reaper breathing down
my back you're gonna I gotta I got
enough pressure to deal with I don't
like that I'm also in the house by
myself right now and let me tell you
something every light is on even in the
apartment yes even in the apartment I I
do have to give it I understand this
there's a thing there's this you know a
psychosis you have when you're by your I
did six weeks by myself why my lady was
gone I don't like it some of those
nights it'd be quiet you'd have the diet
here he you would see him look up into
the hallway or something I got the cat
cats do weird [__] they stand there and
stare at the wall and it's like what the
[__] are you looking at uh-huh there
better be a mosquito or a ladybug or
something like that up there yeah
otherwise you're [__] I call them
genuine holy water there was a couple of
night in the hotel I caught myself
walking through [__] opening the like
checking everywhere checking it under
the bed checking closets that a guy
couldn't fit in but I'm like down there
with a hanger like making sure there's
no legs standing in the clothes you know
I was checking everything I got the
bespoke post slice and dicer right next
to me oh yeah
and under my pillow last night yeah real
calm cool Vibes over there yeah I don't
like it I don't think being alone I was
I was I mean but alone obviously this
we've talked about the summers in this
city it's like for someone to get into
your apartment in the city that's what
they do it they'd have to they'd have to
be a ghost
just you lay it on your back flailing
can't get up well plus I got to come
over here I'll stab you I have the
construction site next door now
somebody could climb up or something
like that
but come down and get me yeah they're
people going to root around yeah they're
junkies they're not climbing [__]
Nine Stories to get your fat ass better
not also if they do
kind of deserve it at that point why
they can come up there and get you they
put the work in I mean what are you
talking about you gotta give it to them
no but there's a thing when you're by
yourself that [__] that thing starts
spinning well the way I the way it I get
I'll be sitting on the couch and I'll
hear something a crack a ding or
whatever the dog will move and I'll go
oh that's nothing I go well what if it
is or nothing and there's a guy waiting
with a sack of pennies to lock me when I
go to take a leak in the middle of the
night I gotta put [__] eyes on this
you know
the second pennies that's a rough way to
go down
[__] changes with a [__] lock in
the socks splits me open like a
pistachio
I was telling somebody the other day I
think I was telling the bird I like when
there's a little goings on
you know what I mean like I you know you
need a little buzz in the end I like a
little bit of energy I like a little
construction I like to hear a little
beep beep beep here a little you know
some some things going on things being
taken care of that's when I sleep the
best because usually when I wake up in
the morning and the construction guys
are working I it's good to knock back
out for an hour it's ah nice
like I turned down I turned my light off
because that's on all night you leave
your light on all night in the room yeah
when I'm by myself in the room you're
sleeping with the lights on yeah whoa
nervous kid what about a TV
I have my phone on
I was watching Johnny Quest last night
when I fell asleep get the carriage and
go to bed will you sleep with the lights
though like this light
I don't have [__] floodlights but
like a lamp or like a ceiling light no a
lamp not the ceiling light you're
sleeping with a lamp on yeah it's not
good to sleep like that either you're
supposed to sleep in darkness yeah it's
not good for your uh
thanks for the heads up yeah it's not
good because I haven't been sleeping
great I've been very tired even with the
CPAP
better than getting got though I'll give
you that hey as a paranoid from one for
one I Got No Escape in there
I mean yeah you're you're pretty jammed
up sure to begin with sure
just yeah I put a bottle next to the
front door and I keep the light on no
really yeah
but you don't when you're by yourself
bottle yeah because if somebody opens
the door you hear it rolling around no
it just lock the door throw the cat in
their face you'd have to [__] kick my
door in to wake me up and then I'm
[__] not if they they got like a
little thing get in there like that
somebody sneak in and so the bottle's
there and I hear that and I guarantee
you wouldn't wake up what are you gonna
do then you're gonna wake up thinking
you're [__] dead already you hear
that bottle if that bottle Falls and
wakes you up you're waking up cat knocks
it over here no he hasn't Bud paranoid
yeah oh I would freak out yeah so that's
not gonna do anything you're better off
just letting them sneak in and kill you
while you're sleeping hey yeah take you
out where the lights I'd immediately
leave
leave where the apartment
get the cat go go [__] we're just
gonna walk hey just give me a minute
we'll even walk by him what do you mean
no if the if the bottle fell
ghost anything I'm out oh you think it's
a ghost whatever
if it's anything if the bottle Falls
somebody either tried to get in or what
if they're in if it falls they might
just come in and go now I gotta kill
them
or would you
see what I'm saying I made noise there's
now a witness no because I had a buddy
of mine now you're just saying that
that's not gonna happen I had a buddy of
mine who's you know I'd rather know and
and let's let's [__] get it on
face to face you're in your robe
it's all the tissues
um because a friend of mine his parents
when they were starting out they lived
in Conshohocken down here down there
outside Philly and they went to bed one
night and the mom woke up in the middle
of the night and just like she just felt
something and woke up but like didn't
really move she knew she like woke up
scared and she just heard this voice go
let's tie him up
no that's
yeah Richard Gere put a gerbil in his
ass what are we doing yeah what do you
mean she told me the story
incredible Witness
I believe her okay my mom told me this
story
I believe I believe the ghost detective
over this let's get to the bottom of
this
uh yeah okay
that could sure listen you do what you
want I got the bottle and the [__]
blade under the pillow and the lights
are on and the cat's on patrol I've seen
you
try to get up after a good night's sleep
let alone [__] I said give me a
second yeah after an intruder I think
that I'm a lighter sleeper than I really
am I would be I would be done I miss
phone calls no that no [__] you miss EV
dude I've been trying there's been hours
where I've been trying to get a hold of
you and you're just off the off the
reservation
tell new guy Luke to pack a bag I pack a
bag if you're staying with uncle Hank
for the next couple of weeks [__]
working nights yeah uh all right let's
see here
um
this one's from Dallas new homie here
question have you ever dined inside a
KFC
of course yeah back in the day
yeah I don't think I've ever taken KFC
out of KFC oh you're crazy we were not a
KFC family oh I mean we weren't I
wouldn't say we're a KFC family but as a
young young kid I remember going to KFC
you know Thursday night whatever getting
a bucket uh and then we talked about it
with Timmy D they used to have these
parfaits they had like a little like a
little cooler case sure in the front
that had like the coleslaw and they had
these parfaits in there which were
phenomenal yeah it was delicious or out
of nowhere when you didn't know what was
going on for dinner you didn't see
anything in the in the sink that was
that was throwing out and then all of a
sudden the old man walked in the door
with a with that bucket
let's go big ass thing of mashies some
slog couple of biscuits for the boys
yeah you ever seen a kid
trick-or-treating with a KFC bucket whoa
yeah that's a different breed that ain't
great
that's nuts holy [__] still a couple
Wings in there yeah cause you can't
really clean those there's grease and
crumbs at the bottom of that greasy ass
Twix bar
that hey use a pillowcase that's what we
used once you get to 12 13 you're using
a pillowcase oh yeah yeah pillowcase
before that and the costume is real
light real open for interpretation yeah
there was always you know there was so
you'd be the times where I was like the
costume was the cut you're like really
trying to wow with the costume as I get
seven eight nine couldn't work with it
though you're hot and sweaty but there
was always that thing too [__] when you
decided you were at the age of like oh
we're gonna meet up his friends now like
there's no parents there's no like I'm
going here to meet up with the boys and
the girl whatever throw a mask on just
throw a mask on and a hoodie and make
with the candy yeah uh but there was
always like one kid who showed up still
like too into the costume that's like
him and his brother they're like a horse
I'm trying to get laid over here I never
did the two-man costume get the [__] out
of here that's like that's like trying
to sneak out of prison you do something
like that
yeah
get your hands in your brother's Pockets
the whole night you're the ass of the
mule get out of here dude uh yeah I
remember one year we did uh ICP me and
my buddy my mom painted our face like
[__] the Insane Clown Posse that's
cool yeah it was pretty if I was young I
wasn't 18. that wasn't it was I we were
young we were
it's [__] 11 10 11 something like
that but I now that I think about it I
think I've rolled up with like the full
face paint numbers like yeah we're
[__] smoking cigs over here dude
you're creeping everybody okay
you a ghost now we're a rapper that I've
only heard one song of I think they got
into wrestling I think at one time like
I think they were on like WWE or WCW and
that's what was like our intro to them
shout out to ICP all right my boy
[__] hung me out to dry one time we
were supposed to go as gangsters at
school
I didn't really have the look I like
borrowed one of my uncle's like
raincoats but it wasn't like a gangster
trench coat it was like like a
businessman yeah yeah and I didn't quite
have the Hat I think my mom made the Hat
it was bad dude I look like an [__]
and I show up and he's got like a full
football uniform on oh he left you that
high and dry yeah he can't because he's
like an insurance salesman
like Ned Ryerson dude it was a tough
look
yeah he got like his brother's like high
school football jersey and his pants and
he came in everything was all ducked he
had the face paint I'm like dude what
the hell [__] I look at his agent or
something like that show me the money he
sucks
like an [__] walking around
yeah that's it man I remember having
walking into school or those things or
those about the carriage of like is this
gonna hit is this gonna hit him you're
already making up excuses in your head
huh whatever you don't know whatever
yeah real tough man though that inner
monologue walking to the bus stop then
you get to the bus stop and someone else
you're the only guy in an outfit or
whatever oh God forbid somebody's
wearing the same costume
man looking like a dork
three Spiderman standing at the bus stop
never took KFC home that's crazy uh name
now that now that you say that I think
my stepmom would get it that's a big
stepmom move right there
should I get a chicken yeah but it was a
a handful of times because I can
remember the wedges at the crib I can
remember that box of wedges at and man
that those like beer battered wedges or
whatever they were all right [__]
okay but I gotta say as a kid I I wasn't
as bad as you but chicken on a bone no
which thing I would guess they gave us
real early
and it was thighs too my mom was big on
thighs you know what a chicken thighs
like to a little kid yeah I felt like
eating a frog I felt like a
paleontologist digging through that to
get to the [__] meat I was like what
can I eat what can I eat we gotta send
this away for testing and the skin would
come off in the first bite then you just
see raw muscles yeah no I didn't like it
I was there for the sides sloth yeah
hook me I remember being like there's a
fast food joint that serves mac and
cheese why the [__] are we living next
to this place
but we would go as teenagers and we
would eat there I think just for like
something to do sure kids in The Burbs
you're like oh let's go kill a half hour
we'll [__] go eat at KFC I remember
eating at all of them Wendy's we talk
about we've talked about the salad bar
I've eaten there I remember
um uh I remember when I didn't want to
eat at McDonald's anymore
when it became sad
when it was like the middle of like the
summer
and you'd be in there and there'd be
like one old man just sitting there
having his lunch by himself and I just
felt so bad for them you know you look
around you're like this ain't this place
ain't jumping yeah wears off eat that
[__] in the car
I made the mistake of getting KFC when I
first moved into the city never go to
one in New York City nuts it's like it's
a [__] war zone it looks squirrel
dude dude it looked like it was cooked
in like a nuclear test facility yeah it
was like black and brown dude it was
awful oh it's bad dude there's that one
on like 14th and second and it's like
ruined like the three blocks around it
there's like a no-fly zone around it
it's just like [__] Street people and
people sleeping it's like a lot no it's
like that it used to be that wall or
that Wawa the McDonald's down on next to
the cellar yeah that thing was rough too
oh yeah I mean that was well it's the
only thing really open 24 7 or open
super late so it's a bunch of you get a
bunch of drunk people you get a bunch of
Street people you just get a bunch of
[__] whoever's up at 3am walking the
streets of New York ends up in one of
those it ain't very good I remember
Duncan the old Dunkin Donuts back in the
day too that would depress the [__] out
of you some of them were all right a
bunch of old men with no families
crushing cigs and eating a plain donut
crushing a coffee in a mug they used to
have mugs I don't know they yeah but
they used to be very I I have memories
of them being like very communal like it
was always like to see a couple of
Old-Timers in there talking to us they
all became friends and then they were
talking before the revamp like do you
remember an old Dunkin Donuts where it
was the counter
they had a counter
like a diner type thing yes no it was
real old school man their donuts were
[__] fine
fine I think they were making them there
but the guy in the commercial said
as of as a somebody whose family used to
by extended family used to own a handful
of Dunkin Donuts they usually do them on
the one property and then give them to
the other ones I don't think now I think
now they're coming in from somewhere no
they're coming in Frozen I think no I
think the one would make them I mean
this wasn't that long ago give that a
goo T-Bone I'm I'm looking up and I'm
looking it up now were they making
Dunkin Donuts they're frozen they're
frozen yep
what they used to make them right in the
store yeah imagine that
imagine that
now why couldn't they have kept that
costs you think yeah for sure anything
you go why don't they do it like they
used to cost it's called everything's
called think about it you got 50 how how
many Dunkin Donuts are there probably
[__] 2 000 way more than that it's
not that I'd say 30 000. 30 000 Dunkin
Donuts there's no in the country yeah
there's no it's probably like five
thousand
Toby uh give me one sec I would say it's
probably less than that yeah Krispy
Kreme makes them I think 9 500 95 9 500.
yeah you are just gonna it's heavy East
Coast I mean they don't have Mountain
Montana and [__] like that how many
McDonald's are there
in the US or worldwide in the U.S
400 000.
no you don't think no 13 000. Jesus
Christ 13.5 yeah whoa look at you that's
not that Johnny franchise is over here
somebody's been doing some digging oh
have you yeah I'll do that what yeah
let's do let's let's open up a a Mickey
D's or something like that no money in
that what are you talking about you
gotta own like 30 of them all right I
twist my arms wet my beat though I'll
tell you that
um no I don't I because there used to be
a a stat that there was more Subways
Subways than McDonald's but it took like
three or four Subways to make the same
amount of money doesn't make that was
like a Snapple fact or something and I
thought the number was like I don't
think it was it was something it was I
mean he knew the fact too so it was like
a known it was a trivia fact floating
out there
um were you a Nantucket nectar's man
that was High doll and [__] right there
I don't think I've ever had one I had
one buddy that would get them at Wawa
and I was like what are you hoity toity
no are those the things that look like
buzz balls what no it's a it's like a
snap it's like a fancy snap yeah it's a
fancy Snapple okay I'm thinking of the
orange uses you know what I'm talking
about it looks like a little grenade
Orangina no it's like apple juice oh
that's a Martinelli's yes sir that's
high quality stuff I've only had that at
two three times in my life he had a
wedding those things are delicious yeah
shout out to Martinelli's you ever had a
buzz ball no that's a good time what's
that they're those they're those little
like Shooters they sell them in 7-Eleven
but they're like on the door of the
freezer it's just like a little ball of
like horrific booze no I think I know
what you're talking about oh yeah they
have like a tag on them don't they oh
yeah yeah
have been jammed up
calling a calling a fire mission in my
own position do you ever guys ever have
game day beer the 7-Eleven beer that
they ran for a minute we're paid at
7-Eleven's not allowed to serve beer in
PA so that's all that's you have to go
to a beer distributor or a bar to get
beers okay well you didn't miss out it
tastes like motor oil but it was like a
dollar for like a 24 ouncer we missed
out we missed out on all that stuff in
Pennsylvania
they just started selling booze in the
grocery stores down here and even that
you got to go to a separate checkout
It's gotta go because that that used to
be controlled by the state like that was
like state owned within the thing
Commonwealth Quakers narcas State dude
yeah it's the Quakers it's all but it's
all old it's all like
so in order to sell beer you have to get
a license from the [__]
State and the guy who controls given the
license for the state it just so happens
that like 14 of his cousins all own
[__] beer distributors you know what
I mean it's all [__]
the power is very a lot of places in PA
are selling their liquor licenses too
because they're so high right now so
there's only a set amount of places in
Philadelphia or Pennsylvania or whatever
the township is five six hundred G's
that are allowed to serve beer so if you
want to open a restaurant you have to
and there's not a liquor license
available there's there's a finite
number so you have to buy it off a guy
who's selling a liquor license so that's
the going rate so if somebody could be
like I want six hundred thousand dollars
for my liquor license there's no set
price
it's all like uh yeah it's great it's I
now that it's wildly corrupt I presume
that's a system built for Greece baby oh
yeah like a Bazaar in Bangkok
you know what I'm talking about
playing ball uh-huh yeah a lot a lot of
grease in the wheels I assume to get get
what you need that's what's that gonna
say when we try to help Cody's place
we'll have to uh Grease the wheels if
there's something I like doing it's like
of course a little grease to get my way
but then they come back looking for more
and if you cave and you're jammed up if
not they throw a brick through your
window so I've heard
talking about Pollocks don't have a
goddamn Future Ain't the Boy Scouts
you're buying those from
I wasn't a band leader either uh all
right let's see here
um this is from Eric never had one red
is it
is the use of the word Crick the
greatest indicator of garbage of a
garbage human being
uh I would say it's up there they think
you know crick of course for Creek yeah
is that I feel like I always thought
that was like uh did you say that
growing up uh my hillbilly cousins did
Crick Crick was big the Neshaminy Crick
Crick was huge it was trick yeah and
then as it was until I got into like
Junior High I was like oh it's Creek a
creek needs a little WD-40 there's a
Creek in the door or a Creek in your
neck uh creepy you could have a crick in
your neck really yeah it's cracking your
neck creaking a door Creek in the door
for sure yeah if I ever heard quick in
the neck yeah got a [__] slept wrong
woke up with a crick in my neck
[Music]
um
but that is I would we call that a
stinger I woke up with a stinger I'll
show you a stinger
to walk out my robot on my Stinger yeah
I got a stinger last night
um Crick is one thing that is as a vocab
so it's Creek versus Crick if you're
from I don't know where in the country
or you're from that might not know Crick
but I mean you're in North Carolina you
know it it's of there's no coming back
from that no if you say crick in
conversation I will look at you what's
up there with hamburger meat roof no
it's way way worse than hamburger roof
can be Regional
roof I like Minnesota I think says rough
Bob Vila used to say roof if you say
Craig mate foreign
did you ever watch This Old House as a
kid with Bob Vila yeah no who is the
other guy I don't know I was more of a
that guy oh when he took over there was
Bob Villa versus someone else we watched
that we were pretty for first trashy as
we were we were pretty heavy into public
television when I was a kid
we only had three channels for a long
time though yeah I mean it was the
[__] 30s
uh they play the old British comedies
and stuff like that we'd sit and watch
them
Lawrence Welk
kill myself brutal uh
guy with Bob veal there was two there
was some doubt that took it over no not
took it over there was two different
shows two different leading home
improvement men
at the time I think in Bob Villa and
there was another guy
building it with Tony
I think it needs to grease the wheels
here it's just in pain
it's just him greasing people for
permits and stuff
can't take any inspector out the dinner
any [__] can make a log cabin all
right try try building a [__]
three-story walk up in Manhattan let me
show you how we should get the cement
Trek to show up on time
that's very
um that's all right back to school yeah
oh yeah yeah that's what that's that
ain't the Boy Scouts that's right that's
from uh what the hell's a widget
uh unless I'm thinking of uh
uh Tim Allen versus Bob Vila which no
there was another one I don't know and I
feel like they were like fighting for re
I feel like each family was a this
family or that family I couldn't I don't
know about that they definitely both
weren't on public television Bob Vila
was was PBS it was public television
you're not talking about that thing
where they would move the bus
no that was extreme home makeup Extreme
Home Makeovers that was Ty Pennington
they were doing the Lord's work
today we're making a lot of money Hill
that show was huge yeah they were
helping families were they yeah they
were given [__] like the most needy
of family I heard all that [__] fell
down after they were gone Bob Villa's
probably still got a couple of
properties up
go walk anywhere on that roof you want
to
put a pool up there I don't give a [__]
that's Timber right there yeah uh no
they were I think they were doing that
was like very [__] they would go and
it would be like for like a mom and a
dad who had like 88 kids and took in
their sister's kids because the sister
was on meth okay the whole thing though
they were having like a daycare in the
basement because whatever I just
remember when they said move that bus
Patty the Waterworks would start all
right all right
then it started really getting caught it
started getting a lot of sponsorship
Sears was doing everything the Maytag
repair man was there [__] yeah yeah
yeah yeah of course I mean you [__]
sure turn a profit something this is
American goddamn I gotta wet my beak
somehow
you just be giving away all this stuff
for free someone's got someone's gonna
pay the brand Stacks at the end of the
day
they pay for all this Lumber he's gonna
he's gonna pay for that goddamn bus uh
all right let's see this is one uh
Rebecca have you or anyone you known
ever executed an upper decker no never I
think maybe one of my boys did if for
The Classy folks out there that don't
know if you don't know it's when you
drop a deuce in the in the tank of the
toilet so when you flush it poop water
comes in yeah and it stays in there it's
not a good scene no I think you gotta
remove
the poop with your hand and then not
your hand but you have to get it out of
the tank fishing it or something and
then keep flushing it yeah to clear out
the water it ain't great I think maybe
one of my boys might have done that at a
party
um at a kid's house that we didn't know
it was like some rich kid's house they
might have done that
I have uh I've turfed a couple of lawns
peeled out in the truck
never any damage little tough guy
um what did you feed the dog that's
pretty mean to do the upper decker yeah
my buddies got kicked out of they went
on a way on spring break and they got
kicked out of the hotel they were in
they did it in their own hotel room no
they did in the lobby
which is a dick move but I remember the
circumstances were like real [__] up
they were like I didn't have the squat
strength to pull that off they were like
get out or something and then like the
left they were like in Cancun oh no they
did it after after that I thought that's
why they got kicked no they got booted
out of the hotel they're in the lobby
they're like this is all like pre
oh let me just pull out my phone and
book a new place on hotels tonight or
whatever they're like oh we have to like
call it traveling it's like figure this
the [__] out somehow so I think the
retribution they [__] somebody went
in not their finest hour no of course
not but hey make mistakes in our youth
what are you gonna do gotta get paid
back somehow I'll have my Vengeance in
this life or another in this Lobby or
another
ah but now you get all you think about
the poor guy that's gotta [__] clean
that out of course he didn't kick out of
the hotel of course no it sucks it's
shitty he wasn't the one doing whippets
upstairs with music blasting all night
either I'm sure they got kicked out for
a probably very logical reason knowing
my Dirtbag friend sure
um
God love them
God love them I also have Pat shout out
to Pat who's done the show he's pooped
in his own front yard before and it
somebody thought there was like a wolf
loose or something the next morning
God damn coyotes
looks like that coyote had a caesar
salad
this Beast has been chewing blunt wraps
yeah cigarettes
yeah
also not his finest moment I presumed
all right this was from CJ
um let's see this one is not about the
show this is a this is a curveball a
little this is a little x-rated oh
but it's a
is it garbage to get a BJ from your
third cousin which I need to look up on
third cousin to be exactly sure what
that is yeah man who may or may not have
been in an exotic dancer
I mean that's got nothing doesn't matter
she was an accountant or not a third
cousin that's your cousin it was only
twice
and it's because she was practicing her
new routine on him
that involve that I think that might
have been a
I'm sure there was sexual tension
between the two obviously
what's a third cousin and so yes I can
tell you I have third cousins okay but a
third cousin would be your one of your
parents first cousin's children nope no
it's even further than that oh really
that's your second cousin third cousin
share a great great grandparent four six
four generations are moved my third
cousin shares a great great grandparent
yeah her great-grandparent great great
that's strangers if you ask me
[Laughter]
um
that's out there I'm not saying it's
right and you're probably both going to
hell but that's out there my cousins we
we share a
uh grandfather no your cousins yeah no
we share a my grandmother and their
grandmother were sisters
just grandmother my grandmother and
their grandmother were sisters
was that like removed right no what do
you mean like I understand but what's
like what's the term twice yeah that
might be great grandparents place to
remove or something not great no
grandparents we hey we got it we're
trying to figure it out
I thought that was third cousins no
you're clearly wrong he just told you
what third cousins was so you're wrong
that's real deep that's great great
share a great great grandmother
grandparent yeah that's deep in the
[__] spider web that's only two two
what that's like 400 years no it's not
it's enough
are they around right now you're alive
you can't do it you throw a couple
Twisted Teas in that mix
he was wearing sunglasses he had a fresh
pair of Oakleys what do you got uh so a
cousin twice removed that means your
cousin is either part of your
grandparents generation or your
grandchildren's generation because they
are two generations removed I don't get
any of that what's the second cup this
feels like I'm taking the SATs and it
sucks I know I feel like I'm watching
someone fail the SATs I feel so dumb
right now because also at the same time
you're thinking about every Thanksgiving
you were ever at I had a shop with Wendy
[__] I blew it if you gotta do
generational math it's no good but we're
not figuring it out so maybe it is okay
first cousins are your cousins first
cousins are your mom or dad's brothers
or sisters kids
that's a no-go
let's start there that's no good all
right we know that's wrong but feels so
right
so we know that's wrong yeah then you
move out a little bit okay to your to
your mom's cousin well all your cousins
are all your first cousins because
they're all direct descendants
we know this
all right
so what's your cousin's kid is your
second cousin my cousin's kid because I
have a bunch of cousins with kids uh
that they would be my second cousins
yeah
no no no no no but but there you're
they're your first cousins those kids
are your first first cousins once
removed yeah once removed don't say yeah
you've been wrong on everything you've
said so far
remember when you were gonna Define
third cousin for us first and that was
wrong I think you said you know what
first removed I don't know what he's
what swinger website he's looking at
you're trying to tip in his favor am I a
hillbilly.org he said no it's cool.com
[Laughter]
I get dirt actually if she can keep her
mouth shut.org
I don't
that's deep in the charts man give me
third cousin again
and I have a feeling
why would you be hanging out with them
if it's that removed
you wouldn't know those things grew up
in the same school district or something
maybe she lived on my blog
third cousin is all right
third cousins share a great great
grandparent so what does that mean a
great great grandparent so you have your
grandparent yes then you have their
parents which would be your great
grandfather correct and then is it his
grandfather or his father his father
so your grandfather's grandparent your
grandfather that guy's long gone dude
nobody even knows that guy's name
anymore he could be the dude that rolls
in with the with the with the wad full
of cash at Christmas not your
grandfather's grandfather that's yeah
your grandfather's grandfather
your grandfather no your grandfather's
father is your great-great-grandfather
that was your great-grandfather oh yeah
[__] oh yeah all right okay
Google see if we can find out what two
cousins board a train in New York where
do they be where where does the incest
happen find out how old a great great
grandfather high pressure situation
either way go to adamandeve.com uh
how old or what the age gap between
somebody today and a great great
grandfather would be is that like a
that's like 120 years because your
grandfather figure if you're one and
your grandfather's 60. okay right yeah
his dad
would be a buck 20 no it wouldn't double
his dad would be 90. okay his dad would
be a hunter you're 120 years away from
the relationship he ain't [__]
showing up nowhere that guy's one plus
the [__] let's see the life
expectancy back in the day I mean that
dude's been out there for a hundred
years yeah all that charcoal meat yeah
get out of here
oh
a couple of times
obviously it's not weird if they buy
I would need some pictures
where'd she dance
she sounds cute yeah uh I don't know
weigh in I think it's listen is it right
no
is that the kind of thing where hey me
and Tammy are dating
okay what would the family say would
that be frowned upon
if you were dating your third depends
how small it depends on how they
pronounce Creek
ah there it is that time you two got
together that's a crick family oh for
sure
hey sure yeah that's a real quick [__]
oh yeah
listen it's probably not great right
but it sounds pretty hot
I've seen his videos what's the but
what's the line
oh what does the family care that's my
thing is like the family doesn't care I
think you're far enough away if nobody
gives a [__] so I was like what if
they're from a small town in like
Appalachian Mountains or something and
it's like oh yeah what's that strip club
like yeah whatever I don't know she's
working on her moves so she's got to be
bringing the [__] heat she's her
she's converting her [__] third
cousin
but it's also they've done the math to
know they probably shouldn't be doing
this
but it could be one of those things of
like you might not meet until you're 20.
oh they moved to town or whatever and
you're like oh this is [__] Debbie
she's actually a great uncle Lester
kids kids oh [__] that then yeah if you
grew up together I'll be yes no this is
all under the guise of I guess you
didn't grow up together I am assuming
these two did
roommates yeah I don't know
but we gotta wrap it up
either way way in I need to plop to
think about it we gotta do a Twitter
poll or something get the people going
Hachi Machi gang let me tell you
something we're out there on the road do
yourself a favor come out and see the
boys yeah we'd love to see it could be
anything else for him guys we're all
over the road like you said the tickets
are moving very quick in most markets so
get those tickets uh we [__] love
everybody we love seeing you out there
it's a good time we'll see you there see
you soon see you next week peace